man baby carriages and the chats
Socrates the graces hi okay
I'm gonna accept another random
challenge you do this one more time
let's do this
accepts well I'm playing Socrates didn't
I just mention Socrates or maybe not
maybe some philosopher mentioned
Socrates but Socrates is a philosopher
okay I am Alive
I'm playing chess let's play Smith Maura
because more gasps Herman I've been
watching like Mark S Herman's YouTube
channel is amazing YouTube channel it's
just a mix of like tennis videos and
chess videos so my two favorite things
play Knight f3 well I think I'll treat
this is a grand prix like develop and
eventually mate Bishop c5 is kind of
annoying maybe I'll do a 590 foreign
invader six also thanks to the new subs
whose names I don't think I read off at
any point in time goo hit 5k six five
four seven and piggy in space appreciate
the support mayhem yeah mayhem in the
Mora it's a good book she's recommend it
I mean the more I accepted is actually
like such a dangerous opening okay
essentially what I'm doing I'm removing
the light and then I'll get an ID for
attacking c5 and e6 and life will be
great not just good but great oh this
chat is so hard to follow Santa Claus
play-doh st. Charles random gifts Erik
back dirty Fargo with a sub thanks dirty
Fargo
what's emos
flappity says also yes Eric needs to try
emos if he hasn't I'll buy him one it
sounds like pizza but I'm not sure let's
play 94 I might be getting Forks but he
might be winning a bishop I might be
having 96 check st. louis-style thing
across pizza
actually I lived in st. Louis and in
Webster for two years and there is an
emos like a block away from my apartment
I never tried it even once I need some
like app which allows people to bring me
food be some nice look I won the bishop
he's winning my bishop or my nights
before Queen gigs before Bishop d2 oh
wait this is bad this is really bad
Queen takes e5 is attacking mates and my
bishop and I can't defend both I have 94
maybe to confuse him this is really bad
though what do I do
I could cry
curl up in a ball or I could fight
debating that's why 94 confuse them yeah
f4 fights that's what X stands for right
my got to like start a poem or a rap and
we'll people clap I do play tennis I
played three hours of tennis earlier
today night f2 what does this move
I have literally four pieces attacked by
multiple different things this is so
terrifying
what is this position I could take a
night with my king and he wins both my
knight and my bishop okay bonk loud
style it's not kinky to buy the skiing
f2 and then King g3 cuz King Power and
I'll probably play rook c1 and at least
control an open file you'll donate bits
to Here I am rosin bust some chess wraps
all I'm so tempted
I don't usually rap though because I'm
not Wesley so yo escargots I'm so slow
like a snail not like email
that's my rap please clock who said that
Jeb Bush wish I was really bad
have I seen Carlson rap I don't think I
have oh I do I I'm pretty sure I have
but it was like scripted but this is
more like freestyle
okay are we gonna repeats or the cheats
but he's not using sock fish because
he's a fish let's play each for blockade
hand grenade and made what else rhymes
with a Gatorade
okay d6 is weak rook D - hey it's bits
so the rap was decent enough I guess um
let's not trade Queens so they want to
attack like there's so many arrows this
has to be good
rook t6 I'm allowing the rook trade Bell
I'll get a pawn to d6 and maybe my
bishop will open up there's still tea in
my cup boo Queen 61 not so fun Jasper
are gifting Suggs what is this Bishop
takes me five attacking or threatening
discoveries also free rook
actually it's it's a rook for two miners
if he takes takes and then I have steaks
wait who are these subs
tarus q and lvg ghosts
welcome to the sub club okay I want to
meet also I want to win a free nights I
think this is winning Oh Queen takes d8
I forgot Queens can move backwards well
the combination look at that I should
have taken with pawn okay now I have to
fight is he gonna play Queen d1 please
play Queen d1 I'm ready to take it Queen
d4 tricked me this is really bad
[Music]
good thing this is casual Queen e2
doesn't work
mmm let's do this okay I have to go for
a mace otherwise I'll lose this is so
painful stop it please play Queen f2 huh
he's so good at chess okay please flag
please play Bishop d7 please ooh free
pawn well the fight
Oh Queen trade this is really bad now I
have to get counter play oh he's winning
another pawn no I have to win the Jeep
on and then promotes before he can
promote don't push your passport this is
so bad who wanted me to rap this is so
bad Queen b1 please play Queen b1 I
can't
mm-hmm okay Queens but it didn't really
work I'm not gonna take the bishop
because there's weird weird still me a
second arise I think this is the first
game to lose on stream Oh No
oh this is so sad please just still meet
me
accept my plea I have to take the bishop
Queen here I resign this is what happens
when there's a wrong Eric who's
streaming what was that game most of
that game was like really bad freestyle
rap